Franklin Delano Roosevelt was the
longest-serving president in US history
serving 12 years in office from 1933 to
1945 he steered the nation through its
worst economic crisis only to be faced
with the most horrific war in history
though facing Titanic physical
challenges of his own he imbued America
with the indomitable fortitude and sense
of morale that was required to spur the
nation on to victory in today's bhaiyya
graphics we examined the inspirational
life of the 32nd President of the United
States Franklin Delano Roosevelt
[Music]
Franklin Delano Roosevelt was born on
January the 30th 1882 the only child of
James and Sarah and Delano Roosevelt in
Hyde Park New York James recorded the
events in his diary that day
writing at quarter to 9:00 my Sally had
a splendid large boy that was
unconscious when he was born
maybe weighs 10 pounds without clothes
it was not an easy birth in fact both
mother and baby nearly died due to the
administration of too much chloroform by
the doctor ah good old medicine back in
the day despite being born not breathing
Franklin went on to become a healthy
child he was raised in a privileged
family living in an impressive estate
that had been in the Roosevelt family
for more than a century the Roosevelts
were of Dutch extraction having
emigrated in 1654 they became an
American success story due largely to
developments in the coal and
transportation industries Franklin's
father a Harvard Law School graduate
served as the vice president of the
Delaware and Hudson Railway and also
served as president for the Southern
Railway security company his income and
his inheritance allowed him to retire to
focus on his health which had never been
very good Sara Delano was the second
wife of James her existence revolved
around caring for her son as a result
the majority of Franklin's early
childhood were spent in the company of
his mother Sarah was an overly
protective parent she came to feel
resentful of anyone who got too close to
Franklin meanwhile James was often the
absent father young Frank think though
he did benefit from the privileges of
wealth and position when he was 5 years
old he visited the White House with his
father President Grover Cleveland spoke
to him personally saying I have just one
wish for you young man that he will
never be President of the United States
Franklin didn't attend school instead
his father employed a private tutor for
him he was enable students he applied
himself to his lessons each summer
Franklin and Sarah would vacation at the
Delano homestead in Fairhaven
Massachusetts that would also be an
annual trip to Europe during these days
Franklin learned to speak German and
French as he grew older Franklin became
an avid sportsman he played lawn tennis
and polo and rode horses and learned to
shoot a rifle in his teens he also took
to golf and sailing it was customary for
children of privilege to attend boarding
school at the age of 12 but Sarah
considered that her glorious boy was not
yet ready to take such a big step and
delayed the move for two years at 14 she
enrolled him at the Groton Episcopal
school at Groton Massachusetts this
court was attended by the children of
the most privileged people although it
was a shocker Franklin to suddenly be
away from the protective care of his
mother he sooner just a dormitory life
he played a number of sports and became
a member of the school debating team as
well as the choir he graduated from the
school in June of 1970 impressive to
secure a spot at Harvard University in
Cambridge Massachusetts a Harvard man
Franklin became very socially active
during his first year he joins a number
of clubs on campus and began writing for
the Harvard College newspaper he
excelled in the college environment
becoming confidence and a popular
student towards the ends of 1900
Franklin's father James he died a year
later another death profoundly affected
him President William McKinley was
killed by an assassin's bullet an act
which propelled Franklin's distant
cousin Theodore Roosevelt to the White
House this change of events serve to
pique Franklin's interest in his family
history he wrote a college paper titled
the Roosevelts of New Amsterdam and
studied the notations in the old Dutch
family Bible
after three years at Harvard Roosevelt
was ready to graduate yes he chose to
stay on for another year in order to
work as the chief editor of the Harvard
Crimson newspaper one day in the summer
of 1902 he was heading back to the
family mansion at Hyde Park from New
York when he happens upon an
eighteen-year-old
Eleanor Roosevelt and yes she did share
his name she was in fact a distant
relative of his the two they hit it off
immediately and from that chance
encounter romance blossomed Franklin he
was captivated by Eleanor's intellectual
depth and her social conscious things
they got serious in 1903 with Franklin
who was now studying law at Columbia
University our ceiling fell on us hand
in marriage she eagerly agreed and
wanted the wedding to take place as soon
as possible
Franklin's mother Sarah was not happy
with her son's choice of bride whether
she had something specifically against
the independently minded Eleanor or she
felt threatened by any woman getting
between her and her beloved boy well
that's unclear she convinced Franklin to
at least delay the wedding which took
place on March the 17th of 1905 eleanor
who was an orphan was given away by her
uncle and that would be President
Theodore Roosevelt the young couple
honeymoons in Europe upon return to New
York Franklin returned to his law
studies at Columbia University in May of
1906 Eleanor gave birth to their first
child who they named Anna Eleanor the
following year Franklin passed the New
York State Bar Exam he secured his first
job as a law clerk it's a prominent New
York law firm the second child James
came along in December of nineteen oh
seven during 1907 Franklin's mother
Sarah had been financing the building of
a double house on 65th Street in New
York it was to be a present to the
couple with her living in one house and
them living in the other their living
spaces they were separated by a single
door while grateful eleanor was
frustrated at the way that sarah was
smothering their marriage making
decisions that should have been
Eleanor's domain this it was a difficult
time in Eleanor's life children were
coming along regularly yet she admitted
that she was not a natural mother she
went so far as to write that she did not
even like her children she hired a nanny
and spent more time on local New York
social issues such as working for
improved factory conditions for workers
[Music]
Franklin's first foray into politics it
came in 1910 when he became a delegate
to the New York Democratic state
committee he was then asked if he wanted
to run for the office of state
assemblyman
it was assumed that the sitting
Assemblyman was about to retire Franklin
he was infused but they found out that
the incumbent was not planning to retire
at all there was though an opening to
run for New York State Senator with no
experience but plenty of enthusiasm he
began a grassroots campaign that soon
endeared him to the working people of
the city he faced an uphill battle with
the state being decidedly Republican
however on election day he found himself
ahead by a thousand votes and he was
suddenly the New York state senator the
Roosevelts now rented out their house in
New York City and moved to the state
capital in Albany New York
Franklin though he soon became embroiled
in political intrigue a powerful faction
of the New York Democratic Party known
as Tammany Hall had run the party for
decades
Roosevelt however was not one to do what
he was told he was not going to be
anybody's puppet he stated his
opposition to the Tammany Hall group and
built his own support network who were
known in the papers as the little group
of insurgents through his adherence to
principle and his refusal to back down
Roosevelt developed a reputation as a
man who would stand up his beliefs as
his first term drew to a close though
Roosevelt was struck down by typhoid
fever which has a 20% death rate he
recovered though and vigorously
campaigned for a second term as New York
state senator he won this one by 1700
votes
Roosevelt was a supporter of Woodrow
Wilson who won the presidency in 1912
Wilson set about rewarding those who had
stood by him in due course Roosevelt was
offered the position of Assistant
Secretary of the Navy
it was the same position that his
distant cousin Theodore had held in 1897
Franklin now gave up his state Senate
seat to take on the new role
Roosevelt this job had him traveling the
country to inspect ships and naval yards
he soon discovered that the Navy was
really quite ill prepared for war and he
campaigned for the creation of a naval
reserve of 50,000 men along with
increased spending on shipbuilding
Roosevelt didn't seem to care that his
words or actions were not politically
expedient his only interest it seemed to
be in bolstering the Navy this attitude
has earned him respects across the
political spectrum with the outbreak of
war in Europe in August of 1914
Roosevelt became even more dedicated to
his work of building up the US Navy he
excelled in the role and won many
advantages for the Navy with the 1916
presidential election Roosevelt's future
it hung in the balance if Wilson
was returned to office he would no doubt
retain his position as assistant Navy
secretary but if a Republican moved into
the White House he would more than
likely be unceremoniously dumped it was
an extremely closely fought race with
Roosevelt later describing it as the
most extraordinary day of my life at the
end of the day Wilson won out to retain
the presidency and Roosevelt's job was
secure with America's entry into the war
in 1917 his position took on more
urgency he was instrumental in the drive
to elicit public donations for the war
effort as well as the developments of
mind detonation technology the pressures
of his work kept roosevelt away from his
family for increasingly long pressures
of time he began an affair with the
social secretary of his wife Eleanor
that would continue on and off until his
death the woman's name was Lucy Mercer
sometime in around in 1918 Ellen I found
the letters between the two they
revealed that franklin was planning to
divorce her and make a new life with
Lucy
however Franklin's mother refused to
permit such a scans or warning her son
that it would ruin his political career
from that point on Roosevelt's marriage
was one of expedience and convenience
ellen assumed set up a separate home in
Hyde Park for her and the children as
she threw herself into her social work
the break in their marriage was so
severe
when Roosevelt asked Eleanor in 1942 to
come back and live with him due to his
poor health she refused in September of
1918 Roosevelt made a state visit to
France and Britain to inspect naval
facilities on the return trip onboard
the USS Leviathan the influenza pandemic
it ran through the ship the number of
people died and Roosevelt became very
ill however he recovered before he
reached New York following the end of
hostilities in 1918 Roosevelt began
looking towards his next run for office
after much consultation he decided to
campaign for the Democratic vice
presidential nomination his bid was
successful and he found himself on the
ticket alongside Ohio Governor James Cox
who was running for presidents Roosevelt
resigned as Assistant Secretary to the
Navy and spent the next year and a half
on the campaign trail the 1920 election
it's ended up being a resounding victory
for the Republicans with warren g
harding securing the presidency
[Music]
Roosevelt accepted the loss with grace
he returned to New York to pick up his
law practice in August of 1921 the
family were vacationing at Campobello
islands when he was struck down with an
illness it was believed that he had
contracted polio myelitis with the
condition paralyzing him from the waist
down more recent analysis suggests that
it may in fact have been an autoimmune
disease called guillain-barre syndrome
sera urged her son to retire and live
out his life in retirement but his
closest advisors including wife Eleanor
they felt otherwise he should continue
with his public career which they
assured him was on a trajectory towards
the White House thus encouraged he spent
the next few years in physical
rehabilitation if he couldn't walk
unaided he would at least project that
impression to the public he taught
himself to walk a few paces with metal
braces on his hips and with the aid of a
cane he was determined that the public
would not see him in a wheelchair in
1926 Roosevelt financed the building of
a hydrotherapy debilitation clinic in
Warm Springs Georgia he spent much of
his time there throughout the remainder
of the 1920s during his rehab years
Roosevelt maintained close contact with
the Democratic Party then in 1928 he
reluctantly ran for governor of New York
he won by a margin of just 1% his
governorship was marked by a focus on
innovative infrastructure projects such
as hydro static power plants in the
institution of his fireside chats during
which he spoke directly over the radio
to the people of New York winning
re-election in 1930 Roosevelt introduced
an economic relief package to help the
millions suffering from the side effects
of the depression he also established a
number of Commission's to root out
public corruption
as the popular two-term governor of the
country's most dynamic State Roosevelt
was a frontrunner for the Democratic
presidential nomination in 1932 he won
the nomination of the Democratic
National Convention in his acceptance
speech he promised I pledge you I
pledged myself to a new deal for the
American people
this is more than a political campaign
this is a call to arms Roosevelt ran on
a platform of government funded public
works farm relief and the repeal of
prohibition on the strength of these
policies and his winning personality
he won 57 percent of the popular vote to
become the 32nd President of the United
States after taking the oath of office
Roosevelt delivered his inaugural
address best known for its famous line
to the inaugural address a woman by the
name of Sarah love said any man who can
talk like that in times like these is
worthy of every ounce of support a true
American has roosevelt assumed office in
the midst of the greatest financial
crisis the united states has ever faced
unemployment it was 25 percent banks
have closed all over the country and
more than two million people were
homeless Roosevelt dedicated himself to
saving the nation he would do so by
putting in place the relief programs of
his first New Deal he restructured
systems that were broken and this
invigorated the spirit of his people
another key to this invigoration were
his far side chats which was something
he continued from his governorship he
spoke to the American people as a loving
father full of optimism and of good
ideas during his first term Roosevelt
established a number of major relief
initiatives these included the federal
relief administration and the Public
Works Administration which provided
employment to a quarter of a million men
throughout the country in August 1935 he
also signs the Social Security Act which
included benefits for the unemployed and
the elderly from 1935 Roosevelt embarked
on his second New Deal squarely focused
on the business community wholesale
changes were made to the banking
industry
and business in order to make things
fairer to the everyday man by 1936
Roosevelt's policies and personality had
made him one of the most popular
presidents in all of history the
election that year it was a landslide
victory with the president taking every
state except Maine and Vermont during
his second term
Roosevelt spent a lot of time embroiled
in legal challenges to many of the
programs that he had brought in during
his first term in 1936 the Supreme Court
was largely conservative
however by 1941 Roosevelt had appointed
seven of the nine justices with growing
tensions between Germany and the other
European nations Roosevelt pursued a
policy of u.s. isolationism
however by mid 1938 with public opinion
in the US firmly against German
aggression towards the Jews he began
building up the military for the
possibility of war when the war broke
out in September of 1939 he actively
looked for opportunities to support
Britain and France Roosevelt struck up a
great friendship with Winston Churchill
who became British prime minister in May
of 1940 the United States it began
supplying an increasing number of
armaments to the British while at the
same time continuing to build up its own
war footing the fall of France after
just six weeks it was a shock to
everyone in America from that point
forward the majority of people they were
inclined towards American intervention
in the European war in 1940 Roosevelt
made the decision to run for an
unprecedented third term as president
there had been a tradition of limiting
presidents to two terms however
Roosevelt was convinced that a change of
leadership in a time of approaching war
would be disastrous for the country
throwing himself into their campaign he
won another overwhelming victory winning
85 percent of the popular vote and 38 of
48 states throughout 1941 Roosevelt
became overtly critical of Hitler he
became furious when Hitler began
threatening American shipping in the
Atlantic declaring we will not let
Hitler prescribe the waters of the world
on which our ships may travel the
American flag is not going to be driven
from the seas either by his submarines
his airplanes or his threats then on
December 7th 1941 more than 350 Japanese
fighter planes launched a surprise
attack on the US Naval Base at Pearl
Harbor Hawaii some 3,000 people lost
their lives dozens of ships were sunk
and many planes were destroyed as they
just sat on the runway the next day
President Roosevelt addressed Congress
with these memorable words yesterday
December the 7th 1941 a date which will
live in infamy the United States of
America was suddenly and deliberately
attacked by naval and air forces of the
Empire of Japan he then asked Congress
to declare war on the Empire of Japan
which it duly did within days the
declaration of war was extended to
include Germany and Italy Franklin
Roosevelt it was now a wartime president
as the US war machine rolled into action
with hundreds of thousands of men being
sent to Europe and the Pacific theatres
of war
Roosevelt focused on building up morale
on the home front
his main vehicle for achieving this was
still his fireside chats On February the
23rd 1942 he told the nation every
American one we shall not stop work for
a single day if any dispute arises we
shall keep on working while the dispute
is solved by mediation or conciliation
or arbitration until the war is won - we
shall not demand special gains or
special privileges or special advantages
for any one group or occupation 3 we
shall give up conveniences and modify
the routine of our lives if our country
asks us to do so we will do it
cheerfully remembering that the chronic
common enemy seeks to destroy every home
and every freedom in every part of our
land with the Americans having just
entered the war the Russians won a
decisive victory in the Battle of
Stalingrad the Nazis they were finally
being pushed back towards Berlin from
the east Roosevelt and his generals they
were convinced that a similar push from
the West would drive the Nazis into
submission the planning for a grand
invasion of Western Europe had begun
throughout 1942 and 43 Roosevelt had a
number of other meetings with Allied
leaders including Churchill Stalin and
the Chinese leader Chiang kai-shek on
June the 5th 1944 President
address the American people with the
following news yesterday on June 4th
1944 Rome fell to American and Allied
troops the first of the Axis capitals is
now in our hands one up two to go the
following day a major step was taken in
taking out the biggest axis power on the
morning of June the 6th 1944 hundreds of
thousands of Allied troops landed on the
beaches of Normandy after fierce
fighting the German army it was pushed
back now the Nazis they were being
squeezed from both sides it was now
clear to Roosevelt that an Allied
victory was coming he began to place his
focus on the logistics of that victory
he spoke of the Allies as a group of
United Nations he was convinced that
only a worldwide union of Nations could
prevent a future war Roosevelt's
championing of what was to become the
United Nations finally brought Woodrow
Wilson's dream to life
Wilson's dream had been the imperfect
League of Nations but as we all know the
United Nations is still around today
with a 1944 presidential election
rapidly approaching Roosevelt said he
felt torn stating all that is within me
cries out to go back to my home on the
Hudson River to avoid public
responsibilities and to avoid also the
publicity which in our democracy follows
every step of the nation's chief
executive such would be my choice but we
have this generation chance to live in a
day and an hour when our nation has been
attacked and when its future existence
and the future existence of our chosen
method of government are at stake
Roosevelt ran for a fourth term but he
did not involve himself in the campaign
still he won again
he was now set to serve out 16 years as
the president of the United States but
it wasn't to be
the stresses of the war had taken a
heavy toll on Roosevelt
he was now 62 years old he looked weary
suffered from high blood pressure in a
weak heart during the summer of 1944 he
came down with a bad cold he was still
sick when he travelled by ship in
February 1945 to Malta for the big three
conference with Churchill and Stalin
Roosevelt was exhausted when he arrived
back in Washington On February 28th
people commented that he looked like he
was dying and they weren't far wrong
all Roosevelt wanted to do now was sleep
at the beginning of April he managed to
escape Washington for his retreat at
Warm Springs Georgia on the morning of
April the 12th
he sat while an artist painted his
portrait they stopped for lunch at 1:00
p.m. 15 minutes later he complains that
he had a terrible headache
then he slumped to the ground he was
experiencing a massive cerebral
hemorrhage Franklin Delano Roosevelt he
died at 3:35 p.m. on the twelfth day of
April 1945 it was just 27 days before
the war in Europe came to an end having
guided his country through its worst
depression and its most harrowing war
FDR was finally at peace historians they
consistently rank Roosevelt's George
Washington and Abraham Lincoln as the
three greatest presidents FDR biographer
Jean Edward Smith wrote of Roosevelt he
lifted himself from a wheelchair to lift
the nation from its knees so I really
hope you found that video inspiring I
think it's the right word for that I
rather enjoyed that one if you did like
it please do give us a thumbs up below
also don't forget to subscribe if you
want more videos from us and hit that
Bell so you actually find out when we
put out new videos we do a few a week so
do that you'll find out about them and
as always thank you for watching
[Music]